James Bond has a massive franchise of 25
films where he saves the world time and
time again with so much violence
villains and Vengeance it can be hard to
keep track grab your popcorn as we
unravel 007's entire filmography from
Connery to Craig I admire your luck Mr
Bond
[Music]
in the first film in the bond series Dr
no bond travels to Jamaica to
investigate the death of the MI6 station
Chief Juan's subsequent investigation
which included multiple attempts on his
life led him to crab key and radioactive
area guarded by a dragon which turned
out to be a tank with a flamethrower
attached their bond and His companion
honey Rider discovered the lair of Dr
Julius snow a scientist who'd been
recruited by the evil organization known
as Specter or special executive for
counterintelligence terrorism revenge
and extortion nose plan involved using
his advancements in radiation to disrupt
the upcoming launches of the Mercury
space program with Rider's help bond is
able to sabotage the effort kill no and
Destroy his lair his success in stopping
Dr No led to a vow of Vengeance from
Specter leadership that would haunt bond
for years Dr No also introduced a key
Bond Ally CIA agent Felix lighter who
would assist him in future missions From
Russia with Love introduced more special
leadership including the mysterious
number one and featured assassins
attempting to lure bond to his death by
stealing a Russian cryptographic device
though several Specter Killers pursued
him Bond was able to both free the
device from Specter control and kill his
assassins the film also introduced
Bond's beloved equipment Master Q
in Goldfinger Bond shifted Focus from
Specter to arik Goldfinger a gold
obsessed megalomaniac who with the help
of smuggle nerve gasp plan to detonate a
dirty bomb in Fort Knox to make the U.S
supply of gold useless this would
increase the value of goldfinger's own
personal gold horde and plunge the world
into economic chaos Bond was able to
thwart goldfinger's plans with the help
of the pilot [ __ ] Galore Goldfinger
also introduced another key part of the
bond Mythos his Aston Martin Spy Car
complete with ejecting passenger seat
Thunderball featured the return of
Specter and a plot led by Emilio Largo
number two in the organization to hijack
a pair of nuclear bombs from NATO and
hold the world hostage with the help of
Largo's former mistress Domino Bond was
able to infiltrate Largo's home to kill
him You Only Live Twice featured another
encounter with Specter including the
organization's mysterious leader Ernst
blofeld with the help of the head of the
Japanese Secret Service Bond went
undercover to find specter's secret
volcano near where a plan to covertly
start World War III was underway with
numerous Japanese operatives fighting
alongside him Bond defeated blofeld but
didn't kill him
On Her Majesty's Secret Service is the
only Bond film to Star George Lazenby as
007 and it's also one of the most
consequential films in the franchise in
that film bond is tracking blofeld when
he meets Teresa Tracy DaVinci who he
began to romance after saving her from a
suicide attempt Tracy's father the head
of a massive European crime syndicate
encouraged the romance and bond agreed
to keep seeing Tracy in exchange for
information about blofeld Bond's
investigation into the head of Specter
ultimately led him to the Swiss Alps
where blofeld established a clinic
claiming to cure people of their
allergies in reality blofeld had
brainwashed 12 women to be angels of
death who would become biological
weapons which sabotaged the food supply
of the world Bond's boss M agreed to
blofeld's Ransom terms but because
blofeld captured Tracy Vaughn decided to
mount an attack on the facility anyway
bond with the help of Tracy's father and
his allies was able to thwart blofeld's
plan but failed to capture the head of
Specter when they reunited Bond and
Tracy were married but the Union was cut
tragically short blowfeld and his
operative Irma blunt staged a drive-by
shooting on Bond's parked car and while
007 survived his new bride was killed
Tracy's death would continue to haunt
bond for years
diamonds are forever marked the final
time in the Eon series that Bond would
be played by Sean Connery and featured
007 battling blofeld yet again this time
the head of Specter was revealed as The
Mastermind behind a diamond smuggling
ring and the construction of a
diamond-encrusted satellite laser that
could detonate nuclear weapons from
space blofeld planned to auction the
satellite off to the highest bidder but
Bond was once again able to stop him
Live and Let Die marked the beginning of
the Roger Moore era of bond an era that
featured no major Specter stories and
instead relied on a slightly more
Standalone style in that film Bond
traveled to the Caribbean island of San
Monique to investigate the deaths of
three different MI6 operatives in less
than 24 hours there he uncovered a plot
by the Island's leader Dr kanaga to
distribute free heroin in a chain of
restaurants and thus increase drug
addiction and therefore drug sales
around the world the whole operation was
disguised by a cloud of voodoo based
Terror to prevent locals from asking too
many questions with the help of
kananga's advisor Miss Solitaire Bond
was able to stop the operation
in his next two Adventures Bond would
encounter several different kinds of
killers who would challenge his place as
the world's deadliest secret agent in
The Man with the Golden Gun Bond
received a golden Bullet From the
titular assassin a reclusive millionaire
named Francisco scaramanga though M
pulled Bond back from official business
007 set out to track down scaramanga
himself and ultimately learned that
scaramanga had stolen a device that
could change the future of energy
production and disrupt the world economy
the two battled on scaramanga's remote
island home near China and bond
ultimately defeated the Man with the
Golden Gun the spy who loved me saw a
bond investigating a series of banished
submarines owned by both British and
Soviet navies he was forced to team up
with Soviets by Anya amasova and the two
uncovered a plot by billionaire
scientist Carl Stromberg to start a
nuclear war using the submarines Bond
and amazovo were able to infiltrate
stromberg's underwater Lair where he
planned to restart civilization after
World War III was fought and stopped
nuclear missiles from reaching New York
and Moscow the spy who loved me also
introduced one of Bond's most memorable
opponents the metal toothed assassin
known only as Jaws
over the course of his next four movies
Bond would Traverse the world while
dealing with everything from Mad
scientists to power hungry Russian
Generals in Moonraker Bond teamed up
with CI agent Holly goodhead to stop
industrialists Hugo Drax from wiping out
the world's human population via deadly
nerve gas and starting a new perfect
civilization from a secret space station
and For Your Eyes Only Bond teamed up
with a vengeful young woman to stop a
secret British targeting computer from
falling into Soviet hands the cold open
features Bond visiting his wife's grave
and battling a slightly disguised
version of blofeld before killing him in
reality blofeld had been removed from
more araban films for legal reasons and
this was the franchise's tongue-in-cheek
way of addressing that an octopussy Bond
again faced scheming Soviet generals
this time he teamed up with the unlikely
title Ally the enigmatic leader of a
cult of women who ran a circus troop to
stop a nuclear bomb plot that would lead
to Soviet dominance in Western Europe
then in A View to a Kill Bond traveled
to San Francisco to stop at business
Titan Max zorin from flooding Silicon
Valley to secure his own Monopoly on the
future of microchips each time Bond was
able to win in the end should have said
in 1987 the bond series passed into the
hands of new star Timothy Dalton who
starred in two very different Bond films
to close out the decade in The Living
Daylights Bond was once again swept up
in Cold War schemes this time in the
form of a KGB Defector who sought 007's
protection when the defecting agent went
missing Bond began investigating and was
swept into a Web of Lies that involved a
cellist a renegade arms dealer and a
defection that may have been staged all
along Licensed to Kill brought a more
personal approach to Bond's work and
re-teamed him with his old CIA friend
Felix lighter when the head of a drug
cartel ordered a Revenge hit on lighter
severely injuring him and killing his
wife in the process Bond set out for
Revenge when M tried to rein him in bond
wouldn't budge and so his license to
Kill was revoked as a rogue spy With a
Little Help from Q bond journeyed to
Central America to seek revenge and
destroy a drug cartel in the process
beg your pardon forgot to knock after a
six-year Gap James Bond returned for the
beginning of the Pierce Brosnan ERA with
GoldenEye a film that heavily relied on
the idea that Bond was the product of a
bygone age dealing with new threats in
that film he dealt directly with the
Fallout from the end of the Cold War in
the form of his former partner 006 who'd
faked his death to transition to Leading
a criminal organization which in turn
planned to use a satellite EMP device to
crash Britain's economy and Tomorrow
Never Dies Bond went toe-to-toe with the
manipulation of the media as he battled
media Mogul Elliot Carver Carver plans
to start a phony war between Britain and
China by creating news meant to inflame
tensions with the help of a deadly
stealth ship and some clever technology
in the World is Not Enough Bond dealt
once again with the Fallout from the
Cold War battling an xkgb agent and in
oil heires he'd once considered a friend
as they attempted to steal Soviet
plutonium to create a bomb to enhance
their own oil interests in Brosnan's
final Bond film home Die Another Day
007's list of modern threats grew to
include North Korea as he battled the
Korean Colonel who disguised himself as
a British billionaire as part of his
scheme to destroy the demilitarized zone
between North and South Korea starting
the Korean War all over again new files
no kills
and it takes two
with the beginning of the Daniel Craig
era of bond Eon Productions decided to
do something new and completely rebooted
the bond timeline though Judy Dench
stayed on for this era of the series ZEM
she was the only real holdover from the
Brosnan days all of Bond's other allies
were recast and bond himself was
depicted as a much younger operative he
gains his double O status in the cold
open of Casino Royale by killing two
people as part of a mission the bulk of
Casino Royale involves Bond
investigating the funding of terrorism
through the dangerous Banker known as
the shiv with the help of British
treasury agents Vesper Lind as the pair
dug deeper into the chief's money and
where it was going they were able to
gain a key Victory via a high-stakes
poker game but the ship retaliated by
kidnapping them both now The Whole
World's Gonna know that you don't
scratch
foreign
the ship was killed by an enigmatic Man
known as Mr White and while Bond was
able to reunite with Vesper he also
discovered she could be a double agent
as Bond attempted to stop vesper's
treachery he was attacked by White's men
Vesper ultimately sacrificed herself and
her supposed betrayal was revealed to be
part of a deal she made with white save
Bond's life vesper's death would
continue to haunt bond for much of the
story that followed and he began his
quest for vengeance by tracking down
White
bonds capture and subsequent
interrogation of Mr White revealed the
existence of a criminal group known as
Quantum the primary villains of Quantum
of Solace the film saw Bond battling the
shadowy group as it attempted to see his
control of Bolivia's water supply to
create a monopoly Bond ultimately
triumphed and in the process was able to
seemingly let go of his grief over
vesper's death Skyfall brought a more
personal mission to the fore as Bond
returned to MI6 after a self-imposed
Exile when the organization's
headquarters was bombed by an unknown
attacker working with them who faced
pressure from her superiors to retire
Bond discovered the Mastermind was x-mi6
agent Raul Silva Silva worked for m in
the years before Bond came along until
she disavowed him and left him to be
tortured by Chinese agents leaving him
disfigured and eager to seek revenge
you going to complain the whole way oh
go on there to check me see if I can
with Silva's grip on MI6 seemingly too
tight to shake Bond and M retreated to
Scotland to Bond's ancestral home
Skyfall once there they prepared for an
assault with the help of The house's
groundskeeper though they were able to
fight off Silva's men and eventually
kill Silva himself and died from her
wounds after the battle leaving bond to
mourn another important woman in his
life
Specter began with Bond investigating a
lead left for him by m against the
wishes of the new M Bond persisted with
his investigations despite a new
privatization effort that led to the
shutdown of the double O program and
found a shadowy organization led by a
man named Franz oberhauser further
investigation revealed that Mr White's
still alive after the events of Quantum
of Solace was somehow connected to this
organization and that oberhauser was
supposed to have died decades earlier
teaming with Mr White's daughter
Madeline Swann Bond discovered that all
of his previous enemies including the
Schiff members of quantum and Raul Silva
could all be tied back to the
organization known as Specter even the
privatization at MI6 which included a
new Global surveillance effort was a
specter-backed attempt to thwart
counter-terrorism agents then it got
worse after capturing Bond oberhauser
revealed that his true name was Ernst
Stavro blofeld and that he'd known Bond
as a boy after Bond's parents died
oberhauser's father took bond in and
began to look at him with such favor
that young Franz decided to seek revenge
he killed his father faked his death and
devoted his life to a massive criminal
Enterprise that he ultimately turned on
bond this massive personal Vendetta
decades in the making culminated with
Bond capturing but not killing blofeld
leaving him free to return for future
sequels
Bond emerged from the film Specter with
blofeld in prison and Madeleine Swann on
his arm and decided it was time to step
away from MI6 in favor of a trip with
his lover hoping to build a future with
Madeleine Bond opted to visit vesper's
grave in Italy and let her go once and
for all when he visited the gravesite
though it was revealed to be a specter
trap which Bond immediately blamed on
Madeleine though he was willing to get
her out of Harm's Way he wasn't willing
to attempt to mend fences yet again
feeling that he'd had enough of
betrayals bond put Madeline on a train
intending to leave her behind forever
and entered retirement from MI6 done
with the life of a hard fighting spy he
retreated to Jamaica to live out the
rest of his days in solitude but as it
always goes with James Bond the past
still had a way of catching up
five years after Bond left Madeleine and
retired from MI6 his old friend Felix
lighter tracked him down with a new
Mission a dangerous new weapon dubbed
Heracles had fallen into the hands of a
terrorist known as Savin Bond
investigated and discovered Heracles was
an mi6-packed weapon and nanobot Cloud
that could kill anyone whose DNA was
placed into its targeting system as Bond
discovered this he also witnessed staff
and orchestrate a plan to use Heracles
to murder every member of Specter and
lost Felix during the mission Furious
Bond turned to blofeld now in prison and
the only surviving member of Specter as
he attempted to interrogate blofeld Bond
inadvertently killed him as the Heracles
Nanobots were in his bloodstream but
coded to kill blofeld that left one more
person with knowledge of Saturn
Madeleine who'd met the villain as a
child desperate to stop Heracles which
had the potential to kill Millions Bond
sought out his former lover and found
more than he bargained for
Bond found Madeleine at her childhood
home in Scandinavia and learned that in
the five years since they'd last seen
each other she'd given birth to a
daughter who she named matild Madeleine
and matild were captured and taken to a
secluded Island where saffin held court
at a poison garden with the help of Q
and Nomi his replacement as agent 007
Bond followed saf into the island with
the goal of saving Madeleine and tilt
and destroying Heracles
Bond and Nomi managed to infiltrate
saffin's Island and made a terrifying
Discovery they had scaled up production
on Heracles and were preparing to use it
on countless victims Around the World
Racing Against Time Bond managed to
rescue Madeleine and matild and get them
to safety then began figuring out how to
stop Heracles the only solution was to
destroy the entire Island which could
only be done via airstrike bonds stayed
behind to open the blast doors on
saffin's facility to ensure the entire
supply of Heracles would be destroyed
only to encounter safin one more time in
the process as a Parting Gift before
dying saffin tainted the dormant
Heracles Nanobots in bond system with
the coded DNA of Madeleine and matild
ensuring that he could never touch
either of them without killing them
confronted with his own death Bond
contacted Madeline who told him matild
was indeed his daughter the airstrike
missiles rained down as Bond looked out
over the ocean putting an end to Daniel
Craig's incarnation of the character
just as he learned he'd left a legacy in
the world Beyond violence
[Music]
Fame is Agent Anya amasova in 1977's the
spy who loved me she continued to act in
the 80s but she hasn't appeared in a
film since to the north of Kathmandu in
1986. since 1981 she's been married to
former Beetle Ringo Starr she's also
been active in charity work forming the
self-help addiction recovery program in
1991. Lois Chiles was offered the female
lead in the spy who loved me but she was
taking a Hiatus from acting at the time
and turned it down but then a couple of
years later she accepted the role of Dr
Holly goodhead in 1979's Moonraker she
continued acting throughout the 80s and
90s and her most recent film role was in
2006's kettle of fish
French actress Carol bouquet achieved
International Fame as the Vengeance
seeking Molina havillock in 1981's For
Your Eyes Only she's continued acting in
dozens of films plays and TV series ever
since in 2014 she served on the jury of
the Cannes Film Festival and in 2017 she
played a serial killer in the French
miniseries La Monte
mod Adams is unique among the actresses
on this list for playing two different
Bond girls first she was Andrea Anders
in The Man with the Golden Gun and then
she was the title crime Lord in 1983's
octopussy she also even had an
uncredited cameo in A View to a Kill she
continued to act regularly until largely
retiring in the late 2000s Tanya Roberts
appeared as Stacy Sutton in 1985's A
View to a Kill and she continued to act
regularly throughout the 90s before
landing her most famous recent role as
Donna's mother Midge on That 70s Show
she ultimately left the show in 2001
though she did return for a brief run of
episodes in 2004. her acting career has
been largely inactive since then
in A View to a Kill Grace Jones was
instantly memorable as the deadly May
Day she's continued to appear
sporadically in films and TV in
subsequent decades but her major Pursuit
as it was before bond is music since
1977 she's released 10 Studio albums and
remains one of the most distinctive
performers of her generation
in 1987 Miriam Diablo kicked off the
Timothy Dalton era as Cara milovi in The
Living Daylights she's continued to work
as an actress and model ever since in
2002 she hosted the documentary Bond
girls are forever in 2007 she suffered a
near fatal brain hemorrhage from which
she thankfully later recovered Carrie
Lowell played Pam Bouvier in 1989's
license to Kill and she's continued to
act to this day she had a major role as
Jamie Ross on Law and Order beginning in
1996. in the mid-2010s her divorce from
Richard Gere was the subject of a
three-year legal battle as of 2018 she's
returned to TV with roles on Blue Bloods
and bull in 1995 the Pierce Brosnan era
of bond began complete with a new money
Penny in the form of Samantha Bond who
appeared in all four Brosnan films since
the Brosnan era ended she's continued to
act in a little bit of everything her
most recent high-profile role was Lady
Rosamund payneswick on the hit series
Downton Abbey the Brosnan era also
brought with it a new female email M
Judy Dench played the head of MI6 as a
tough resourceful woman who could keep
bond in his place she was so good that
she stayed on into the Daniel Craig era
until M's death in 2012 Skyfall and
since she is named Judy Dench her career
has kept chugging along in 2019 she will
be seen in adaptations of Artemis Fowl
and cats can you get to boss him about
and
um and
there is a very special relationship I
think between between Bond and M
Isabella skarubko was already a
successful model singer and actress when
she was cast as Natalya in 1995's
Goldeneye her other memorable acting
work includes roles in Exorcist the
beginning and Reign of Fire in 2011 she
returned to singing with a collaboration
with Swedish vocalist Peter yubak and in
2012 she served as a host of Sweden's
Next Top Model
Famke Jansen achieved breakout success
as Xenia onetop in Goldeneye
[Music]
on the top
who rocketed her to stardom and helped
land her the role of Jean Gray in the
X-Men franchise since then she's acted
regularly in the likes of Taken and
Hemlock Grove she will soon be seen in
the Netflix original series Central Park
5.
Michelle yeoh established herself
throughout the 1990s as a major player
in Hong Kong action Cinema before
breaking out worldwide in 1997's
Tomorrow Never Dies in 2000 she again
wowed International audiences in
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon and has
continued big screen success ever since
most recently in Crazy Rich Asians
Terry Hatcher appeared in Tomorrow Never
Dies as Paris Carver a former flame of
bond who's now the trophy wife of a
villainous media Mogul she was already a
TV Superstar with Lois and Clark and
after Bond she had another big hit in
the form of Desperate Housewives more
recently she's returned to the world of
DC Comics with a recurring role on the
CW's Supergirl
Denise Richards was at the height of her
Fame when she played Christmas Jones in
1999's the World is Not Enough since
then she's continued to appear in plenty
of films and taken on a career as a
reality TV personality she starred in
her own series Denise Richards it's
complicated and in 2019 she joined the
cast of The Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills
French actress Sophie Marceau achieved
Blockbuster success as the villainous
Elektra King in the world is not enough
she's continued to work steadily as an
actress writer and director ever since
in 2002 she made her featured
directorial debut with speak to me of
love and in 2015 she served on the main
competition jury for the Cannes Film
Festival
Oscar winner Halle Berry was already a
major star when she played Jinx and
Pierce Brosnan's final Bond film 2002's
Die Another Day her career has suffered
a few missteps along the way but she's
rebounded and continued to work steadily
in film and TV among her most notable
projects since Bond are returned to the
X-Men series and kingsman the Golden
Circle the Daniel Craig era required a
memorable Bond girl to kick things off
and it got one with Ava Green as Vesper
Lind in Casino Royale the role made
green an international star she's since
gone on to roles in the likes of Penny
Dreadful and Miss Peregrine's Home for
Peculiar Children in 2019 she can be
seen in Tim Burton's live-action Dumbo
remake
after a successful modeling career
ukrainian-born French actress Olga
Kurylenko landed the role of Camille
Montez in 2008's Quantum of Solace she
has since continued to earn high-profile
roles in films like Oblivion the death
of Stalin and Johnny English strikes
again as of 2018 she lives in London
with her son and boyfriend
Naomi Harris was a 10-year veteran of
film acting by the time she landed the
part of the third big screen money Penny
in Skyfall and she immediately won fans
over with her portrayal she reprized the
role in 2015 Specter and has since
garnered a claim for her work in
Moonlight and appeared in major releases
including Rampage and Mowgli legend of
the jungle
Lisa do has been acting for more than a
decade but in many ways her career is
still very young she achieved
International Acclaim in 2013 for her
role in blue is the warmest color and
parlayed that into her role as Dr
Madeline Swann in 2015's Specter she's
expected to reprise her role for the
25th Bond film in 2020 a rare Repeat
Performance for a Bond girl
Bond fans certainly can cherry pick
their favorites but there's really only
one way to view these Adventures as the
work of one semi-ageless operative and
it's not in chronological order you've
been watching James Bond movies all
wrong and here's why to start at the
characters beginning memes 2006's Casino
Royale the franchise reboot that served
as Daniel Craig's Bond debut based on
Fleming's first Bond novel the film
gives Bond a gritty origin story in
which he earns his double O status
drives off with his signature Aston
Martin and uses his Brawn as well as his
wits like when he flings an empty
handgun right back in an opponent's face
most importantly the film refreshes the
Trope of a woman who does him wrong by
having a genuine love story with an
unwilling betrayal Ava Green's treasury
liaison Vesper Lind throws real Sparks
with Crick revealing a striking
complexity beneath Bond's flinty gaze
Phoebe Waller Bridge the fleabag star
and co-screenwriter of no time to die
told GQ he let us in a bit which makes
the moment he shuts us out even more
arresting overall he grounded a Fantasy
character in real emotion which is what
I think we hadn't realized we'd missed
amongst the action and the bravado
Quantum of Solace released in 2008 picks
up where Casino Royale left off with
Bond discovering that criminal Banker Le
shift is part of a larger terrorist
organization called Quantum he also figs
out more about vesper's past
unfortunately the writer's Guild strike
at the time hampered a cohesive plot
with Craig admitting to GQ we didn't
have a script so we concentrated a lot
on the stunts Craig's third outing
Skyfall continued to develop Bond as a
character particularly his relationship
with M after a botched Mission with new
agent Eve bond is presumed dead but when
vengeful ex-agent Raul Silva targets M
and MI6 Bond returns as Ms protector
taking her to Skyfall his childhood home
in the Scottish Highlands there viewers
see the headstones of his parents and
their surname confirms that James Bond
is the same character across the
franchise admittedly won without much of
a secret identity Bond defeats Silva but
M dies throwing off the continuity when
Dench turns up in the Pierce Brosnan
years
as much as the Craig films serve as
Bond's origin story 2015 Specter also
delves into his connection with the
criminal organization a frequent
adversary from Fleming's novels on the
trail of Mr White a character from
Casino Royale and Quantum of Solace Bond
learns that the quantum organization is
a specter subsidiary he also meets
white's daughter psychologist Madeline
Swann the two follow spector's Trail to
Morocco where they wind up prisoners of
a manned Bond recognizes as Franz
oberhauser son of a foster father from
Bond's youth oberhauser reveals that his
current's name is Ernst Stavro blofeld
which rings the bell for Bond
aficionados as oberhauser he'd faked his
death and now he's in charge of Specter
which has an MI6 mole with designs on a
global surveillance network of course
Bond foyles blofeld's plan then drives
off with Swan leaving Espionage behind
no time to dive forces him back into the
field as CIA pal Felix lighter asks him
for help in pursuing safu an anarchist
and X Specter assassin meanwhile blofeld
stirs up trouble while in custody and a
secret from Swan's past surfaces it's
safe to assume that whatever else no
time to die has in store Bond's
relationship with Swan won't survive
Dr No released in 1962 officially
introduced moviegoers to Fleming's
secret agent along with the concept of
the Bond girl and an eccentric power
crazy villain Sean Connery's Bond heads
to Jamaica to investigate the slaying of
another British agent discovering that
the death is connected to recent
sabotage of the U.S Space Program his
investigation leads to a private island
where he encounters honey Rider a
gorgeous diver searching for seashells
the two meet the Island's owner Dr
Julius no A specter agent and nuclear
scientist aiming to take over a U.S
rocket launch as revenge for both the
Americans and the East not recognizing
his genius thanks to bond his plans end
in a meltdown Connery's follow-up 1963s
From Russia with Love further explore
Specter and its nefarious plans as Bond
goes undercover to meet Tatiana Romanova
a Russian Cipher clerk wanting to defect
with the decoder device she turns out to
be an unwitting Pawn in a specter
assassination plot against bond for
killing Dr known Bond strangles one
Specter assassin and goes toe-to-toe
with another wielding a poison spike in
her shoe Romanova comes to his defense
proving that love conquers all
definitely one of the most memorable
Bond films Goldfinger finds Bond looking
into auric Goldfinger a gold magnate who
smuggles the stuff out of England
through the Bodywork of Israel's Royce
but Goldfinger has a grander scheme in
mind destroying the gold Reserve in Fort
Knox with an atomic bomb rendering it
useless and thus cementing his wealth
to enter Fort Knox Goldfinger enlists an
Elite Squad of female Pilots to spray
nerve gas which will kill thousands Bond
winds over the improbably named Squadron
leader [ __ ] Galore before stopping the
bomb with a precise
007 seconds to spare Connery told the
New York Times at the time it sort of
demonstrates what I believe is a subtler
more discriminating Bond than you've
seen in the earlier films I guess I'm
trying to make James Bond grow up a
little in the same way that I'm growing
up myself not too much though definitely
not too much that would spoil the fun
for both of us
Thunderball released in 1965 sends bond
to the Bahamas to recover two nuclear
warheads that Emilio Largo seconded
command at Specter hijacks for ransom
swiping them involved brainwashing a
pilot and sending him for plastic
surgery something Bond discovers while
visiting a health spa for some r r under
M's orders eventually Bond pieces
together that the brainwashed pilot whom
Spector kills is the brother of domino
Largo's mistress You Only Live Twice
released in 1967 showed Connery's Bond
at last meeting Specter leader earned
Stavro blofeld after an attempt on
Bond's life complete with a Burial at
Sea Bond re-emerges and joins forces
with tiger Tanaka of Japanese
intelligence Tanaka suggests that Bond
Mary to pose as a local fisherman so he
can investigate Undercover the bride is
another agent kissy Suzuki who is all
business the two uncover a secret
Specter base within a volcano where
blofeld hoped to deceive the Soviets and
Americans its starting World War 3. with
those plans thwarted kistian Bond decide
to enjoy their honeymoon until MI6
interrupts
Australian actor George Lazenby stepped
into Bond's shoes in 1969's on Her
Majesty's Secret Service after he
rescues the suicidal contestant Tracy
deficenzo from drowning in the opening
moments she drives away leaving Bond
dumbstruck and spurring theories of
James Bond being a code name with a
cheeky aside to the camera
this never happened to the other fella
the Espionage plot is a little kooky
this time around with blofeld running an
allergy clinic in the Swiss Alps that's
really a way to brainwash attendees into
Distributing biological warfare but
that's secondary to Bond's relationship
with Tracy the spirited but troubled
daughter of a mob boss Tracy a skilled
skier as well as driver gamely helps
Bond throughout the movie and the two
marry toward the film's end then blofeld
and an assassin pepper their car with
bullets after the ceremony killing Tracy
and leaving Bond poignantly holding her
behind the shattered windshield
Connery returned his bond in 1971's
diamonds are forever which begins with
him tracking down blofeld to an
underground lair where the Specter
leader prepares for plastic surgery Bond
ties blofeld to an operating table and
plunges it into a steaming Mud Lake
presumably avenging Tracy's death
although his late wife isn't mentioned
elsewhere in the film welcome to hell
bluefeld as Bond investigates who is
stealing huge quantities of diamonds he
learns that the blofeld in the lair was
actually a double for the real blow felt
currently hanging out in Las Vegas under
the guise of multi-millionaire Willard
white with the help of conniving Jewel
Smuggler Tiffany case Bond figures out
that the diamonds are powering a space
satellite and the laser aimed at nuclear
installations around the world they stop
the destruction of course although
Tiffany wonders if there's any way to
get those sparklers back to Earth
Roger Moore took over as 007 in 1973's
Live and Let Die more definitely brought
a lighter touch to bond but this film's
black exploitation influences haven't
aged well well you just keep on the tail
of that jukebox and there's an extra 20
in it for you hey man
20 bucks
the plot is Bond checking out a heroin
operation controlled by a Caribbean
dictator and a gangster both of whom are
actually the same person in Disguise
there's a lengthy motorboat chase a
wince inducing Southern Sheriff
alligators Voodoo and some duplicitous
consent with the film's women
blaxploitation actress Gloria Hendry
playing a field agent and the tarot
reader Solitaire Moore's next Bond film
1974 is The Man with the Golden Gun
finds himself the target of Francisco
scaramanga the world's most expensive
assassin who kills with a single shot
from a specialized weapon bond also
delves into the work of a scientist
wanting to harness the sun's power to
solve the energy crisis when M calls him
off that mission for his safety Bond
ignores him learning that scaramanga is
after not just Bond as a trophy but the
solar technology as well
with Specter seemingly gone the Bond
films of the 1970s into the 1990s
focused more on Cold War antagonists the
spy who loved me from 1977 does that
with the cheekiness and excess of the
more era but for some reason it all
works when British and Soviet nuclear
submarines vanish Bond follows a lead to
Cairo where he runs across Russian major
Anya omosovo working the case from the
Soviet end the two format tenuous
Alliance to defeat wealthy shipping
entrepreneur Carl Stromberg who wants
the submarines to launch Armageddon so
he can create a new civilization Beneath
the Sea Stromberg likes sharks that
devour enemies and has a metal tooth
tenchman named Jaws for all its Flash
the film also has a notable callback to
Bond's late wife Tracy many lady friends
but married only once wife killed one
two major point
blame the success of Star Wars for
launching Bond into space with 1979's
Moonraker a film that copies the basic
plot of the spy who loved me with that
film's henchman jaws now working for a
different megalomaniac who wants to kill
people and start over fresh this time
Hugo Drax A supplier of space shuttles
to the US government makes off with a
shuttle to transport a new master race
to his space station it's not enough to
leave Earth behind though Drax also has
concocted a lethal toxin to kill the not
so worthy humans trapped on the planet
the film includes a wild Chase through
Venice where a gondola becomes a
hovercraft and a full-on laser battle in
space Bond also gets a hand from one of
the smarter women of the Moore era an
astronaut and CIA agent with the eye
rolling name of Holly goodhead at least
she can pilot to shuttle
Bond went more Down to Earth for 1981's
For Your Eyes Only the agent searched
the Mediterranean for a missing British
ship equipped with a weapons encryption
device meaning Molina Havelock a
crossbow wielding woman whose parents
worked for the British government her
quest for revenge against whoever killed
them dovetails with the secret KGB agent
christantos and a Greek Smuggler the
film includes realistic action scenes
both underwater and during a mountain
climbing climax but first it closes the
book on Specter in the opening moments
his bond visits the grave of his late
wife Tracy a helicopter arrives to whisk
him back to MI6 once in the air a surge
of electricity through the headset kills
the pilot and blofeld now using a
wheelchair takes control of the craft
from the ground the agent manages to rip
out cables connecting blofeld's remote
control then flies after his one-time
Nemesis scooping up the wheelchair on
one of the Chopper's skids and dropping
him down a smokestack
for Moore's final two Bond outings the
agent again dealt with cold war
machinations in 1983's octopussy Bond
becomes involved with a jewelry Smuggler
and circus owner who gives the film its
title she's in League with exiled Afghan
Prince Kamal Khan who's actually using
her circus operation to Stage a nuclear
accident with a rogue Soviet General
there are acrobatic thieves a hunt in
India that's an homage to the short
story The Most Dangerous Game and
disguises for bonds that include an ape
costume and a clown suit Moore hung up
his Walther PPK after 1985's A View to a
Kill which pitted Bond against
industrialist Max soaring a psychopath
thanks to failed Soviet steroid
experiments zorin has a striking
henchwoman named Mayday and designs on
destroying Silicon Valley through an
earthquake so he can control the
microchip Market naturally a San
Francisco geologist helps spawn disrupt
zorin's plans resulting in a showdown
Atop The Landmark Golden Gate Bridge
Royal Shakespeare company actor Timothy
Dalton starred as bond in 1987's The
Living Daylights as the guardian noted
his more nuanced and complex
interpretation hewed closer to Fleming's
novels but perplexed fans accustomed to
the quippy more years Dalton is
introduced during a training exercise at
the Rock of Gibraltar where an assassin
picks off several agents until the film
reveals the new 007 defecting KGB
General Georgie coskov says his former
Superior has revived a spy assassination
program but Bond later learns that
koskov is in League with an American
Arms Dealer and wants the man dead for
business reasons because of the AIDS
epidemic bond is a one-woman man this
time around forging a romance with Cara
molovi a cellist who had been koskov's
girlfriend Dalton's follow-up 1989's
license to Kill finds Bond on a
cold-blooded personal Crusade against a
drug dealer whose men leave Felix
lighter for dead and kill his bride Del
before her death Della wonders why their
friend James hasn't found a steady
sweetheart and Felix briefly explains
that he was once married
because of legal issues Bond didn't
return to theaters until 1995's
GoldenEye which starred Pierce Brosnan
after Dalton resigned the film starts
about a decade before the present day
with Bond on a job with fellow double O
agent and friend Alec trevelyn who
seemingly dies of course events in
Bond's life are rarely what they appear
and bond later learns that Alec is alive
and leading a crime syndicate he seeks a
satellite-based electromagnetic pulse
weapon known as GoldenEye the filmmakers
attempted to update bond for modern
audiences by giving him a female M who
criticizes him I think you're a sexist
misogynist dinosaur a relic of the Cold
War
but some Bond things never change they
also gave Alec a leggy accomplice zenya
anatop likes to crush victims between
her thighs bond gets some assistance
from a CIA contact who disconcertingly
calls Bond Jimbo as well as Natalya a
Russian computer programmer who flirts
with getting bond to settle down
Brosnan's second outing 1997's Tomorrow
Never Dies explores more of bonds passed
by introducing a former girlfriend Paris
now married to Elliot Carver a tabloid
medium oval Carver draws mi6's attention
after a spurious signal from one of his
company's communication satellites
occurs at the same time a British
warship sinks in Chinese Waters Paris
helps Bond infiltrate her husband's
headquarters for Old Times Sake for
which Carver has her Kilt Carver has a
more unusual scheme for a bond villain
he wants to secure exclusive
broadcasting rights in China in exchange
for starting a war between the British
and the Chinese fortunately Bond finds
an ally in Wei Lin a Chinese agent who
can handle herself
1999s The World is Not Enough packed an
impressive twist at M's request Bond
retrieves money from a Swiss Banker for
British oil tycoons to Robert King a
particular sum that turns out to be
treated with an explosive bond deduces
that someone wanted to send a message by
killing king through the cache because
King's Daughter Elektra had recently
been ransomed for the same amount of
money although he presumes that the
terrorists who kidnapped Elektra is
responsible King's killer turns out to
be Elektra herself she has developed
feelings for her kidnapper and the two
want to detonate a nuclear explosion in
Istanbul leaving the King Pipeline the
only viable route for extracting
petroleum from that region along to
defuse the situation as a nuclear
physicist with the eye roll-inducing
name of Dr Christmas Jones
Brosnan's tenure is Bond finished in
2002's Die Another Day released the same
year as the 40th anniversary of Dr No
the film pays homage in some ways to
other previous Bond films and Fleming's
novels one such nod having Bond pick up
the book of Field Guide to Birds of the
West Indies whose author James Bond
inspired the name of Fleming's famous
spy the plot mirrors some elements of
previous entries within adversary whom
Bond thought was dead assuming a new
identity to build a space laser out of
diamonds NSA agent Jinx Johnson teams up
with bond in a story that becomes more
Fantastical than some fans liked Bond
surfs through an iceberg tsunami there's
an ice palace and the Aston Martin
Vanquish becomes invisible although he
felt shocked over being replaced at
first Brosnan in 2020 said he has quote
no regret over his 007 days telling the
guardian bond is the gift that keeps
giving and has allowed to have a
wonderful career once you're branded as
a bond it's with you forever
James Bond wouldn't be half the Spy he
is if he didn't have some killer
villains to square off against
since 1962 he's been facing down some of
the toughest bad guys in movie history
we're here to give you a glimpse of what
they look like today hey from Le Chief
to Hugo Drax
in the 25th the Bond film no time to Die
the villainous and mysterious saffin
will be played by Rami Malek Malik is
best known for playing protagonist
Elliot Alderson in the television series
Mr Robot and Freddie Mercury in the film
Bohemian Rhapsody he's been active since
the early 2000s playing small roles in
shows like 24 and Gilmore Girls and
films like Night at the Museum Mr Robot
was the launch pad he needed and it
appears Malik will only continue to
climb higher in Hollywood
Christoph vaults his breakout role
arrived in 2009 when he blew audiences
away as SS officer Hans Landa and
Quentin Tarantino's and glorious
bastards vaults went on to secure major
roles in movies like Django Unchained
and eventually 2015's Specter Waltz is
the latest actor to play Ernst Stavro
blofeld a recurring Bond villain played
officially by five different actors over
six decades in this continuity blofeld
is actually Bond's adoptive brother who
believes Bond supplanted his position as
favored son
blofeld is the head of the global
criminal organization's Specter which is
secretly responsible for the events of
the previous three films you killed them
I did
vaults has continued to act since
Specter having appeared in a wide
variety of films including Elita battle
Angel The Legend of Tarzan and
downsizing vaults will reprise his role
as blofeld in 2020's bond installment no
time to die
Javier bardem's first work as an actor
happened early he began acting as a
child in 1974 and went on to appear in
many movies throughout the 1990s and
2000s
culminating in his star-making turn as
Psychopathic killer Anton sugar in
2007's No Country for Old Men this led
to bigger roles including Raul Silva in
the 2012 Bond film Skyfall Silva is a
former MI6 agent who was brutally
tortured after M traded him to the
Chinese government and returned for six
captured agents Skyfall sees him become
a cyber terrorist out for bloody revenge
on M following Skyfall Bardem has
continued acting most prominently
playing the mysterious male lead in
Darren aronofsky's mother and Armando
Salazar in Pirates of the Caribbean Dead
Men tell no Tales
Matthew amalrique started acting in
1984's favorites of the Moon and his
most notable performances pre-bond are
his roles in the diving bell and the
Butterfly and Munich in 2008 Amal reek
made his bond debut as the villainous
Dominic green and Quantum of Solace
green is an environmentalist
entrepreneur who secretly works for the
mysterious organization known as Quantum
this evil Collective is buying up
Bolivia's supply of fresh water creating
a monopoly that will make green
exponentially richer at the expense of
the Bolivian people Amal reek has
remained very active as an actor
appearing in movies like Venus and fur
and shows like Wolf Hall among many
other credits
Mass Mickelson enjoyed worldwide
recognition for his role as the chief
and Casino Royale a mathematical genius
with Chief finances various terrorist
groups but ultimately loses their money
in Risky Investments this forces him to
set up a high-stakes poker game in an
effort to compensate for his losses
Bond enters the game hoping to prevent
Le Chief from paying back his debtors
and force him into seeking protection
from MI6
Mickelson's acting career exploded in
the wake of Casino Royale the years
since have seen him take on high profile
roles such as casilius and Doctor
Strange and Dr Hannibal Lecter in the
celebrated television series Hannibal
Stevens has enjoyed a robust career in
acting since 1992 including performances
in 12th night and the title role in the
2000 TV movie adaptation of The Great
Gatsby he assumed the role of bond
antagonist and Die Another Day as Gustav
Graves a British billionaire with a dark
secret Stevens has remained very active
since Die Another Day most notably he
starred as Captain Flint in Black Sails
and as John Robinson in the 2018
reimagining of Lost in Space
Scottish actor Robert Carlisle started
acting in the 1990s taking on roles in
films like Trainspotting and the full
monty in 1999 he faced James Bond as the
villainous Reynard and The World is Not
Enough Raynard previously survived an
assassination attempt by MI6 but it left
a bullet in his brain now he seeks
revenge against MI6 by any means
necessary since his turn in the World is
Not Enough Carlisle has taken on a
variety of notable roles in film and
television he appeared as Dr Nicholas
rush in Stargate Universe portrayed
Rumpelstiltskin and once upon a time and
took on the role of prime minister
Robert Sutherland on the television
series Cobra Welsh actor Jonathan price
started his career on the British stage
of the 1970s and later moved to film
with projects like Brazil in 1997 price
played the bond villain Eliot Carver and
Tomorrow Never Dies Carver is a
sociopathic media Baron who plans to
expand his Empire by inciting a war
between China and the UK price has
enjoyed a number of Stellar roles since
Tomorrow Never Dies he's earned a
particular Acclaim for his performances
as Pope Francis in the two popes whether
be swan in the Pirates of the Caribbean
movies and the High Sparrow in Game of
Thrones
before playing a bond villain Bean
performed Shakespeare on stage and
earned roles in films like Patriot Games
and black beauty in 1995 he took on the
role of Alec trevalian a fellow MI6
agent and close friend to James Bond in
Goldeneye the two conduct a mission
together in which trevalian is seemingly
killed but nine years later it's
revealed that he staged his death and
betrayed MI6 to become a crime Lord Bean
has continued to have a very successful
career Landing roles in The Lord of the
Rings trilogy National Treasure and Game
of Thrones
Robert Davi has enjoyed a rich acting
career since the 1970s appearing in such
Classics as The Goonies and die hard in
1989 he starred as International drug
lord Franz Sanchez and Licensed to Kill
Sanchez's master plan is quite simple
really he wants to continue to sell
drugs on a massive scale and corrupt or
kill anyone who gets in the way
after playing a bond villain Davi has
continued acting in a wide variety of
projects including Predator 2 Stargate
Atlantis Criminal Minds The Expendables
3 and more
Dutch actor yiron krabe began acting in
the 1960s enjoying particular
distinction from his work and soldier of
orange and the Fourth Man the late 80s
saw him play a string of villainous
roles which brought him widespread
Acclaim most prominently General koskov
in the 1987 Bond film The Living
Daylights koskov is a brilliant Soviet
General who feigns neutrality in the
Cold War in reality he plans to misuse
Soviet funds to buy a large supply of
opium and trade it for arms
kerbe went on to play many more famous
villains including Johnny Franco and The
Punisher Charles Nichols and The
Fugitive and even Satan himself the 1999
TV movie Jesus he continues to act and
is also an accomplished painter
Joe Don Baker started his acting career
with parts in westerns like wild Rovers
going on to earn major attention for his
roles in Charlie Varick and Walking Tall
in 1987 Baker played the war obsessed
arms dealer Brad Whitaker in The Living
Daylights baker has continued to act in
the Years following The Living Daylights
though the last decade did see him grow
considerably less active before this
slowdown Baker appeared in movies like
Congo and even returned to the bond
franchise he played the very different
role of Bond's Ally Jack Wade and
GoldenEye and Tomorrow Never Dies
prior to taking on bond Christopher
Walken earned a claim for his roles in
Classics like Annie Hall the Deer Hunter
and the dead zone in A View to a Kill he
played Tech Giant Max zorin who planned
to destroy Silicon Valley to eliminate
competition for his microchip business
after playing Max zorin Watkin has
maintained a very active career he's
appeared in Batman Returns Pulp Fiction
ants Sleepy Hollow Catch Me If You Can
and many other notable films walk-in is
also a frequent host of Saturday Night
Live where you likely best know him for
being in an unforgettable sketch with an
unforgettable line
guess what
I got a fever
and the only prescription is more
cowbell
Julian Glover has been acting since the
1950s taking on a wide variety of roles
and Productions including The Empire
Strikes Back equator mass and the pit
and the Avengers in 1981 Glover found
himself face to face with James Bond as
the villain Aristotle cristatos and For
Your Eyes Only prostatos appears to be a
respectable war hero and businessman but
is later revealed to be a heroine
Smuggler and double agent after playing
a bond villain Glover has continued to
have a very successful acting career
most prominently Glover played Walter
Donovan in Indiana Jones in the Last
Crusade voiced aragog and Harry Potter
in the Chamber of Secrets and portrayed
Grand maester py cell in Game of Thrones
Michael Lonsdale has appeared in over
180 different films and television shows
however his most famous role is likely
still Bond villain Hugo Drax from the
1979 film Moonraker Drax is an extremely
wealthy businessman who owns a company
that builds space shuttles being rich
and Powerful has clearly gone to drax's
head as he wants to wipe out humanity
and restart Society with a few selected
humans using his spacecraft he and his
master race plan to orbit the planet
until toxins kill everyone below
Lonsdale continued to enjoy a rich
acting career post tracks notably he won
a Cesar award for his performance as
Luke in the 2010 film of Gods and Men
and remained active on screen until
2016. he passed away in September of
2020.
french actor Louis Jordon gained major
Acclaim for playing Suave roles in
French and American films working
closely with big names like Alfred
Hitchcock and Elizabeth Taylor in 1983
Jordon played the villainous Kamal Khan
and octopussy Khan an exiled Afghan
Prince starts out as a jewelry Smuggler
whose plans get bigger and deadlier when
he helps smuggle an atomic bomb into
West Germany after playing a bond
villain Jordan continued acting in film
and television until his retirement in
1992. in 2015 Jordon passed away at the
age of 93.
Richard Keel played henchman Jaws in the
spy who loved me and Moonraker Jaws is
extremely strong and Tall forcing Bond
into creative approaches when fighting
him his most striking feature however
are his metal teeth which can bite
through even the hardest Metals in an
interesting plot twist Jaws ends up
undergoing a major change of heart
turning on his boss and helping Bond
defeat Drax Jaws even gets a girlfriend
in the end well
Here's to Us
Keel continued acting after playing Jaws
appearing in roles like Mr Larson and
Happy Gilmore he passed away in 2014 at
the age of 74.
curd Jurgens filmography is extensive
before his bond days he starred in films
like the enemy below and the longest day
then in 1977 Jurgens took up the bond
villain mantle and the spy who loved me
playing the ocean obsessed Carl
Stromberg who plans to start a nuclear
war and start a new life for Humanity at
Sea Jurgens continued acting after his
role in the spy who loved me with roles
in the Sci-Fi Sports drama Golden Girl
and the war film breakthrough his last
role was General Vladimir and the BBC
miniseries Smiley's people he passed
away in 1982 at the age of 66.
it's no surprise that the late
Christopher Lee played a bond villain
his impressive acting career contains
many villainous roles from Saruman and
the Lord of the Rings series to Count
Dracula in the hammer horror films in
1974 Lee took on the role of Francisco
scaramanga and the Man with the Golden
Gun an Infamous assassin with a famous
weapon scaramanga also has a flying car
and a secret Island to scaramanga it's
not about eliminating Bond it's about
besting him this is the part I really
like
Lee remained very active as an actor
leading up to his death in 2015 at the
age of 93. in addition to his work in
major franchises like the Lord of the
Rings and Star Wars in which he played
Count Dooku he also enjoyed a career as
a heavy metal vocalist
yafet Koto is the Sinister Dr kananga in
1973's Live and Let Die simultaneously a
dictator and a gangster kananga's plan
is to freely distribute heroin at his
restaurants bankrupt his competitors
then raise his prices Koto went on to
enjoy more major success as an actor
including his role in the NBC television
series homicide life on the street he's
also widely known as Parker an alien and
Alonso Mosley in Midnight Run
Baron samdi played by Jeffrey holder is
one of the most frightening bad guys in
the bond franchise appearing in 1973's
Live and Let Die he's a witch doctor of
the fictional Caribbean island of San
Monique who works for the main villain
Dr kananga outside of bond holder
enjoyed a stellar career as an actor
dancer musician and artist on both stage
and scream with roles in films like
Annie and Boomerang holder passed away
in 2014 at the age of 84. English actor
Charles Gray actually appeared in You
Only Live Twice as a different Bond
character but in 1971 he returned to the
franchise as the main villain Ernst
Stavro blofeld and diamonds are forever
this time blowfeld has physically
altered his henchmen to look like him
Bond must identify and stop the real
blofeld who plans on using a satellite
built out of diamonds to destroy the
world's arsenals gray continued acting
post blofeld playing roles like the
criminologist in The Rocky Horror
Picture Show and Mycroft Holmes in the
1984 TV series Sherlock Holmes he passed
away in 2000 at the age of 71.
Telly Savalas gained Fame for roles in
films like The Greatest Story Ever Told
The Dirty Dozen and Birdman of Alcatraz
then in 1969 Savalas portrayed Ernst
Stavro blofeld and on her majesty Secret
Service blofeld is threatening the world
yet again in this movie this time
through biological warfare he
brainwashes women putting them into a
hypnotic state in which they distribute
bacterial agents capable of devastating
the world's agriculture after Bond foils
his plans blofeld kills Bond's wife
Tracy which furthers the feud between
the two epic rivals
sabalas continued to play big roles post
blofeld including starring in the
popular television series Kojak Savalas
remained active as an actor right up
until his death in 1994 at the age of
72.
and You Only Live Twice Ernst Stavro
blofeld is portrayed by British actor
Donald Pleasence who ended up creating
one of the most recognizable villains in
the entire bond series
his blofeld has a secret base hidden
inside a volcano where he dispatches
orders with his white cat in his lap
after bringing blofeld to life Pleasants
remained very active as an actor playing
notable roles in the Halloween franchise
Prince of Darkness and More in 1995
Pleasants passed away at the age of 75.
Adolfo Chely specialized in playing
villains with a Cosmopolitan Edge it's
no surprise then that he played Emilio
Largo in Thunderball with such Panache
Largo's evil plan is to steal warheads
and blackmail NATO into paying him a
large sum of money lest he start
destroying major cities
went on to act in numerous roles post
Largo including the Borges and danger
diabolic and continued acting right up
until he passed away in 1986 at the age
of 63.
Gert fruba played the title role of gold
obsessed madman auric Goldfinger in
Goldfinger one of the quintessential
Bond films the film's plot features
goldfinger's attempt to Rob Fort Knox in
order to drive up the price of gold and
also includes one of the most famous
lines in the franchise
after his turn as one of the most iconic
Bond villains ever furuba continued to
have a rich acting career on stage and
scream his roles in Chitty Chitty Bang
Bang and those Magnificent Men and their
flying machines saw him gain particular
Acclaim and very different genres
musical fantasy and comedy respectively
he passed away in 1988 at the age of 75.
even though he isn't the main villain of
the movie odd job is one of the most
memorable parts of Goldfinger played by
Harold cicada his weapon of choice is
his hat which has a razor-sharp steel
rim odd job is terrifyingly good at
assassinating victims by hurling his hat
at high speed though our job was
cicada's first role as an actor after a
successful weightlifting career it
definitely wasn't his last he went on to
perform in Productions like Hawaii 5-0
impulse and dimension 5. cicada
occasionally spoofed his role as odd job
in later years most prominently by
appearing in a series of Vicks cough
syrup commercials he passed away in 1982
at the age of 62.
Lottie lenya played Rosa kleb a
high-ranking member of the mysterious
Specter organization in From Russia with
Love cleb one of the franchise's first
villains is remembered best for her
signature weapon poison tipped blades
concealed in the tips of her shoes
lenya was already a respected actor
pre-bond thanks to an acclaimed stage
career and roles in films like the Roman
spring of Mrs Stone she was also an
accomplished singer and was inducted
into the American Theater Hall of Fame
in 1979. two years later in 1981 she
passed away at the age of 83.
Joseph Wiseman had the honor of playing
the first Bond villain Julius no in
1962's Dr No Julius no has a killer
outfit a complex backstory and an epic
underground layer where he plots to
start a war between the Russians and
Americans like so many Bond villains who
would follow him no also has a unique
physical trait prosthetic metal hands
Wiseman continued to act after his turn
as Dr No appearing in the Twilight Zone
Magnum PI MacGyver and more Wiseman
passed away in 2009 at the age of 91.
James Bond has a massive franchise of 25
films where he saves the world time and
time again with so much violence
villains and Vengeance it can be hard to
keep track grab your popcorn as we
unravel 007's entire filmography from
Connery to Craig I admire your luck
mister
Bond
James Bond in the first film in the bond
series Dr no bond travels to Jamaica to
investigate the death of the MI6 station
Chief Bond's subsequent investigation
which included multiple attempts on his
life led him to crab key and radioactive
area guarded by a dragon which turned
out to be a tank with a flamethrower
attached their bond and His companion
honey Rider discovered the lair of Dr
Julius no a scientist who'd been
recruited by the evil organization known
as Specter or special executive for
counterintelligence terrorism revenge
and extortion nose plan involved using
his advancements in radiation to disrupt
the upcoming launches of the Mercury
space program with Ryder's help bond is
able to sabotage the effort kill no and
Destroy his lair his success in stopping
Dr No led to a vow of Vengeance from
Specter leadership that would haunt bond
for years Dr Noe also introduced a key
Bond Ally CIA agent Felix lighter who
would assist him in future missions from
Russia sure would love introduced more
Specter leadership including the
mysterious number one and featured
assassins attempting to lure bond to his
death by stealing a Russian
cryptographic device though several
Specter Killers pursued him Bond was
able to both free the device from
Specter control and kill his assassins
the film also introduced Bond's beloved
equipment Master Q
in Goldfinger Bond shifted Focus from
Specter to arik Goldfinger a gold
obsessed megalomaniac who with the help
of smuggle nerve gasp plan to detonate a
dirty bomb in Fort Knox to make the U.S
supply of gold useless this would
increase the value of goldfinger's own
personal gold horde and plunge the world
into economic chaos Bond was able to
thwart goldfinger's plans with the help
of the pilot a sea Galore Goldfinger
also introduced another key part of the
bond Mythos his Aston Martin Spy Car
complete with ejecting passenger seat
Thunderball featured the return of
Specter and a plot led by Emilio Largo
number two in the organization to hijack
a pair of nuclear bombs from NATO and
hold the world hostage with the help of
Largo's former mistress Domino Bond was
able to infiltrate Largo's home to kill
him You Only Live Twice featured another
encounter with Specter including the
organization's mysterious leader Ernst
blofeld with the help of the head of the
Japanese Secret Service Bond went
undercover to find specter's secret
volcano layer where a plot to covertly
start World War III was underway with
numerous Japanese operatives fighting
alongside him Bond defeated blofeld but
didn't kill him
On Her Majesty's Secret Service is the
only Bond film to Star George Lazenby as
007 and it's also one of the most
consequential films in the franchise in
that film bond is tracking blofeld when
he meets Theresa Tracy davinciens who he
began to romance after saving her from a
suicide attempt Tracy's father the head
of a massive European crime syndicate
encouraged the romance and bond agreed
to keep seeing Tracy in exchange for
information about blofeld Bond's
investigation into the head of Specter
ultimately led him to the Swiss Alps
where blofeld established a clinic
claiming to cure people of their
allergies in reality blofeld had
brainwashed 12 women to be angels of
death who would become biological
weapons which sabotaged the food supply
of the world Bond's boss M agreed to
blofeld's Ransom terms but because
blofeld captured Tracy Vaughn decided to
mount an attack on the facility anyway
bond with the help of Tracy's father and
his allies was able to thwart blofeld's
plan but failed to capture the head of
Specter when they reunited Bond and
Tracy were married but the Union was cut
tragically short blowfeld and his
operative Irma blunt staged a drive-by
shooting on Bond's parked car and while
007 survived his new bride was killed
Tracy's deaths would continue to haunt
bond for years
diamonds are forever marked the final
time in the Eon series that Bond would
be played by Sean Connery and featured
007 battling blofeld yet again this time
the head of Specter was revealed as The
Mastermind behind a diamond smuggling
ring and the construction of a
diamond-encrusted satellite laser that
could detonate nuclear weapons from
space blofeld planned to auction the
satellite off to the highest bidder but
Bond was once again able to stop him
Live and Let Die marked the beginning of
the Roger Moore era of bond an era that
featured no major Specter stories and
instead relied on a slightly more
Standalone style in that film Bond
traveled to the Caribbean island of San
Monique to investigate the deaths of
three different MI6 operatives in less
than 24 hours there he uncovered a plot
by the Island's leader Dr kanaga
distribute free heroin in a chain of
restaurants and thus increase drug
addiction and therefore drug sales
around the world the whole operation was
disguised by a cloud of voodoo based
Terror to prevent locals from asking too
many questions with the help of
kananga's advisor Miss Solitaire Bond
was able to stop the operation
from England in his next two Adventures
Bond would encounter several different
kinds of killers who would challenge his
place as the world's deadliest secret
agent in The Man with the Golden Gun
Bond received a golden Bullet From the
titular assassin a reclusive millionaire
named Francisco scaramanga though M
pulled Bond back from official business
007 set out to track down scaramanga
himself and ultimately learned that
scaramanga had stolen a device that
could change the future of energy
production and disrupt the world economy
the two battled on scaramanga's remote
island home near China and bond
ultimately defeated the Man with the
Golden Gun the spy who loved me saw Bond
investigating a series of vanished
submarines owned by both British and
Soviet navies he was forced to team up
with Soviets by Anya amasova and the two
uncovered a plot by billionaire
scientist Carl Stromberg to start a
nuclear war using the submarines Bond
and amosovo were able to infiltrate
stromberg's underwater Lair where he
planned to restart civilization after
World War or 3 was fought and stopped
nuclear missiles from reaching New York
and Moscow the spy who loved me also
introduced one of Vaughn's most
memorable opponents the metal toothed
assassin known only as Jaws
over the course of his next four movies
Bond would Traverse the world while
dealing with everything from Mad
scientists to power hungry Russian
Generals in Moonraker Bond teamed up
with CIA agent Holly goodhead to stop
industrialist Hugo Drax from wiping out
the world's human population via deadly
nerve gas and starting a new perfect
civilization from a secret space station
and For Your Eyes Only Bond teamed up
with eventual young woman to stop a
secret British targeting computer from
falling into Soviet hands the cold open
features Bond visiting his wife's grave
and battling a slightly disguised
version of blofeld before killing him in
reality blofeld had been removed from
more era Bond films for legal reasons
and this was the franchise's
tongue-in-cheek way of addressing that
an octopussy Bond again faced scheming
Soviet generals this time he teamed up
with the unlikely title Ally the
enigmatic leader of a cult of women who
ran a circus troop to stop a nuclear
bomb plot that would lead to Soviet
dominance in Western Europe then in A
View to a Kill Bond traveled to San
Francisco to stop the map business Titan
Max zorin from flooding Silicon Valley
to secure his own Monopoly on the future
of microchips each time Bond was able to
win in the end should have said
in 1987 the bond series passed into the
hands of new star Timothy Dalton who
starred in two very different Bond films
to close out the decade in The Living
Daylights Bond was once again swept up
in Cold War schemes this time in the
form of a KGB Defector who sought 007's
protection when the defecting agents
went missing Bond began investigating
and was swept into a Web of Lies that
involved a cellist a renegade arms
dealer and a defection that may have
been staged all along Licensed to Kill
brought a more personal approach to
Bond's work and re-teamed him with his
old CIA friend Felix lighter when the
head of a drug cartel ordered a Revenge
hit on lighter severely injuring him and
killing his wife in the process Bond set
out for Revenge when em trying to rein
him in bond wouldn't budge and so his
license to Kill was revoked as a rogue
spy With a Little Help from Q bond
journeyed to Central America to seek
revenge and destroy a drug cartel in the
process
beg your pardon forgot to knock after a
six-year Gap James Bond returned for the
beginning of the Pierce Brosnan ERA with
GoldenEye a film that heavily relied on
the idea that Bond was the product of a
bygone age dealing with new threats in
that film he dealt directly with the
Fallout from the end of the Cold War in
the form of his former partner 006 who'd
faked his death to transition to Leading
a criminal organization which in turn
planned to use a satellite EMP device to
crash Britain's economy and Tomorrow
Never Dies Bond went toe-to-toe with the
manipulation of the media as he battled
media Mogul Elliot Carver Carver plans
to start a phony war between Britain and
China by creating news meant to inflame
tensions with the help of a deadly
stealth ship and some clever technology
in the World is Not Enough Bond dealt
once again with the Fallout from the
Cold War battling an xkgb agent and in
oil heires he'd once considered a friend
as they attempted to steal Soviet
plutonium to create a bomb to enhance
their own oil interests in Brosnan's
final Bond film home Die Another Day
007's list of modern threats grew to
include North Korea as he battled the
Korean Colonel who disguised himself as
a British billionaire as part of his
scheme to destroy the demilitarized zone
between North and South Korea starting
the Korean War all over again
no kills
and it takes two
with the beginning of the Daniel Craig
era of bond Eon Productions decided to
do something new and completely rebooted
the bond timeline though Judy Dench
stayed on for this era of the series ZEM
she was the only real holdover from the
Brosnan days all of Bond's other allies
were recast and bond himself was
depicted as a much younger operative he
gains his double O status in the cold
open of Casino Royale by killing two
people as part of a mission the bulk of
Casino Royale involves Bond
investigating the funding of terrorism
through the dangerous Banker known as
the shiv with the help of British
treasury agents Vesper Lindt as the pair
dug deeper into the shift's money and
where it was going they were able to
gain a key Victory via a high-stakes
poker game but the shiff retaliated by
kidnapping them both now The Whole
World's Gonna know that you're done
foreign
was killed by an enigmatic Man known as
Mr White and while Bond was able to
reunite with Vesper he also discovered
she could be a double agent as Bond
attempted to stop vesper's treachery he
was attacked by White's men Vesper
ultimately sacrificed herself and her
supposed betrayal was revealed to be
part of a deal she made with white to
save Bond's life vesper's death would
continue to haunt bond for much of the
story that followed and he began his
quest for vengeance by tracking down
White
bonds capture and subsequent
interrogation of Mr White revealed the
existence of a criminal group known as
Quantum the primary villains of Quantum
of Solace the film saw Bond battling the
shadowy group as it attempted to see his
control of Bolivia's water supply to
create a monopoly Bond ultimately
triumphed and in the process was able to
seemingly let go of his grief over
vesper's death Skyfall brought a more
personal mission to the fore as Bond
returned to MI6 after a self-imposed
Exile when the organization's
headquarters was bombed by an unknown
attacker working with them who faced
pressure from her superiors to retire
Bond discovered the Mastermind was x-mi6
agent Raul Silva Silva worked for m in
the years before Bond came along until
she disavowed him and left him to be
tortured by Chinese agents leaving him
disfigured and eager to seek revenge
foreign
[Music]
with Silva's grip on MI6 seemingly too
tight to shake Bond and M retreated to
Scotland to Bond's ancestral home
Skyfall once there they prepared for an
assault with the help of The house's
groundskeeper though they were able to
fight off Silva's men and eventually
kill Silva himself and died from her
wounds after the battle leaving bond to
mourn another important woman in his
life
Specter began with Bond investigating a
lead left for him by him against the
wishes of the new M Bond persisted with
his investigations despite a new
privatization effort that led to the
shutdown of the double O program and
found a shadowy organization led by a
man named Franz oberhauser further
investigation revealed that Mr White
still alive after the events of Quantum
of Solace was somehow connected to this
organization and that oberhauser was
supposed to have died decades earlier
teaming with Mr White's daughter
Madeline Swann Bond discovered that all
of his previous enemies including the
Schiff members of quantum and Raul Silva
could all be tied back to the
organization known as Specter even the
privatization at MI6 which included a
new Global surveillance effort was a
specter-backed attempt to thwart
counter-terrorism agents then it got
worse after capturing Bond oberhauser
revealed that his true name was Ernst
Stavro blofeld and that he'd known Bond
as a boy after Bond's parents died
oberhauser's father took bond in and
began to look at him with such favor
that young Franz decided to seek revenge
he killed his father faked his death and
devoted his life to a massive criminal
Enterprise that he ultimately turned on
bond this massive personal Vendetta
decades in the making culminated with
Bond capturing but not killing blofeld
leaving him free to return for future
sequels
Bond emerged from the film Specter with
blofeld in prison and Madeleine Swann on
his arm and decided it was time to step
away from MI6 in favor of a trip with
his lover hoping to build a future with
Madeleine Bond opted to visit vesper's
grave in Italy and let her go once and
for all when he visited the gravesite
though it was revealed to be a specter
trap which Bond immediately blamed on
Madeleine though he was willing to get
her out of Harm's Way he wasn't willing
to attempt to mend fences yet again
feeling that he'd had enough of
betrayals bond put Madeline on a train
intending to leave her behind forever
and entered retirement from MI6 done
with the life of a hard fighting spy he
retreated to Jamaica to live out the
rest of his days in solitude but as it
always goes with James Bond the past
still had a way of catching up
five years after Bond left Madeleine and
retired from MI6 his old friend Felix
lighter tracked him down with a new
Mission a dangerous new weapon dubbed
Heracles had fallen into the hands of a
terrorist known as Savin Bond
investigated and discovered Heracles was
an mi6-packed weapon and nanobot Cloud
that could kill anyone whose DNA was
placed into its targeting system as Bond
discovered this he also witnessed sap
and orchestrate a plan to use Heracles
to murder every member of Specter and
lost Felix during the mission Furious
Bond turned to blofeld now in prison and
the only surviving member of Specter as
he attempted to interrogate blofeld Bond
inadvertently killed him as the Heracles
Nanobots were in his bloodstream but
coded to kill blofeld that left one more
person with knowledge of Saturn
Madeleine who'd met the villain as a
child desperate to stop Heracles which
had the potential to kill Millions Bond
sought out his former lover and found
more than he bargained for
Bond found Madeleine at her childhood
home in Scandinavia and learned that in
the five years since they'd last seen
each other she'd given birth to a
daughter who she named matild Madeleine
and matild were captured and taken to a
secluded Island where saffin held court
at a poison garden with the help of Q
and Nomi his replacement as agent 007
Bond followed saf into the island with
the goal of saving Madeline and tilt and
destroying Heracles
Bond and Nomi managed to infiltrate
saffin's Island and made a terrifying
Discovery they had scaled up production
on Heracles and were preparing to use it
on countless victims Around the World
Racing Against Time Bond managed to
rescue Madeleine and matild and get them
to safety then began figuring out how to
stop Heracles the only solution was to
destroy the entire Island which could
only be done via airstrike bonds stayed
behind to open the blast doors on
saffin's facility to ensure the entire
supply of Heracles would be destroyed
only to encounter saffin one more time
in the process as a Parting Gift before
dying saffin tainted the dormant
Heracles Nanobots in bond system with
the coded DNA of Madeleine and matild
ensuring that he could never touch
either of them without killing them
confronted with his own death Bond
contacted Madeline who told him matild
was indeed his daughter the airstrike
missiles rained down as Bond looked out
over the ocean putting an end to Daniel
Craig's incarnation of the character
just as he learned he'd left a legacy in
the world Beyond violence
now time to die is all about endings
bringing Daniel Craig's 15-year run as
James Bond to a close it's a sprawling
epic that's both action-packed and
tragic it also does something no Bond
movie before it has ever done this is
the ending of no time to die explain
every Bond movie has an extravagant
villain with an even more elaborate plan
for world domination no time to die has
new threat to Lucifer saffin a
megalomaniac with a grudge and the
peculiar worldview who thinks of himself
as a kindred spirit to bond nice and
sticking
she came to my own reflection earlier in
the film Bond traces a Russian scientist
to expect a meeting in Cuba there he
discovers that blofeld is still running
the Shady organization from behind bars
through the use of his bionic eye
blofeld attempts to use a bioweapon
that's been acquired from the scientists
orbachev A genetically targeted virus
made of Nanobots called project Heracles
to kill Bond but orbachev at the behest
of his true boss Suffin reverses the
programming of the weapon to kill every
member of Specter in attendance instead
safin saves Bond's life as he once did
for Madeleine Swan bonds are strange to
lover when Madeline was a young girl
sappin sought revenge against her father
Mr White for killing his family he
killed Madeline's mother but chose to
spare her life and mercy he uses for
leverage later in the film to make her a
pawn in his successful plot to kill
blofeld and end Specter forever bond has
been suspicious of Madeline since the
film's opening scene when she led him
into a trap at the grave of Vesper Lind
but Bond soon realizes the Trap was
entirely blofeld's plan to drive them
apart seeing that she has been used by
outside forces Bond runs to Norway to
find Madeline and finds a big surprise
awaiting him
five years passed and no time to die
from the film's harrowing opening
breakup between Bond and Madeleine to
the main thrusts of the story but when
bond reunites with Madeleine and
apologizes for the time they've lost
while apart he discovers she has a
daughter matild though Madeleine and
cessie is not the father it is very
clear she is not telling the truth after
he meets his daughter Madeline fills
bond in on her past with safin how he
saved her life and has a strange
obsession with her and how his parents
used to be the chief poison makers for
Specter bond with help from Q is able to
track safety is base on an island in
murky international waters between
Russia and Japan where he has
manufacturing project Heracles on a
grand enough scale to deploy it globally
but before bonds can embark on his
mission to kill safin and stop project
Heracles from spreading further safin
and his men come and kidnap Madeleine
and their daughter bond misinfiltrates
saffin's island with the help of the new
007 know me while trying to avoid
sparking an international incident and
causing even more trouble for MI6 the
agency that helps develop this deadly
weapon in the first place Bond the Nomi
storm sapphins base neutralizing
orbachev and mowing their way through
safin's henchmen bond is able to reunite
with the kidnapped pair and also he now
knows for certain that one is indeed his
daughter Naomi gets him off the island
to safety so he can get to the center of
the base and disable the Blastoise
shielding but protects safin's operation
from outside harm m is prepared to
authorize a surgical strike of missiles
to destroy saffin's Island and prevent
project Heracles from being deployed but
it can't be done until Bond destroys the
defense system it's a suitably harrowing
nail-biting sequence complete with a
ticking clock of inbound missiles but in
his final altercation with safin bond is
exposed to a version of the bioweapon
that's genetically locked to Madeleine's
DNA in killing safin Bond Dunes himself
because if he makes it off this island
and comes into contact with Madeline or
his daughter he will infect and kill
them both resigned to his fate Bond
lowers the Island's defenses and saves
his final goodbyes overcomes to the love
of his life and the daughter he never
got to know
James Bond is dead Long Live James Bond
back at MI6 headquarters M eulogizes
bond by sharing a drink with Nomi Q
Tanner and Moneypenny over the course of
the last few films each of these former
colleagues has developed their own
meaningful rapport with Bond and the
knowledge that he died saving the world
cuts off from a daughter he didn't even
know he had weighs heavily on the entire
group elsewhere Madeline drives off into
the sunset with daughter in tow still
struggling with loss but looking at her
daughter who she remarks as James's eyes
she promises matild to tell her a story
a story about a man named Bond James
Bond
so what happens now do I look like I
give a damn James Bond has never died in
a movie before despite 24 previous films
full of near-death experiences because
of the franchises murky continuity none
of the other bonds final outings who are
creatively conceived that way up until
Casino Royale intentionally rebooted the
series the first 20 movies essentially
followed the same James Bond
but with no time to die being imagined
from the outset as Craig's final outing
the filmmakers felt free to tell a story
with far more finality than any Bond
movie before it but just because this
bond is dead it doesn't mean James Bond
himself is being retired the last
message in the credits Echo is what so
many other Bond movies before I have
promised James Bond will return not 007
James Bond that basically proves we'll
be getting another reboot of the
character in the next Bond movie leading
up to no time to die new entries in the
bond franchise have elicited think
pieces about whether or not Bond can
still work on screen in a changing world
man talk
no time to die improves you don't have
to drastically change Bond as a person
instead you need to change the world
around him and create drama out of that
juxtaposition whether the next take on
bond is a drastic departure or a careful
refinement to what has come before the
Bold conclusion for no time to die has
set the stage for bond to endure he is
to the next 25 movies
[Music]